[Music]
all right now would not be a good time
to fall behind on your credit card
payments average interest rate on a
retail credit card is now a whopping
29% while service retail specific credit
cards they're charging over 30% I've
never heard rates like that in my life
and now is definitely not the time to
refinance your house either with
mortgage rates now averaging 8% for
30-year fixed rate mortgage under Donald
Trump we were in the 2% range the 3%
range so what can you do now we need a
change in leadership and that change
could start well in about 17 days in the
Commonwealth of Virginia here with more
is Governor Glenn yunan you know we have
two-thirds of the country Governor
living paycheck to paycheck some people
just are using their credit cards just
to be buy Bare Necessities what are they
to do
here well Sean Joe Biden's foreign
policy has caused International chaos
and his border policy
has called has caused a national
security a drug and a humanitarian chaos
and bomic is causing an economic chaos
and you're 100% right families are
living paycheck to paycheck I mean for
the average family in Virginia and
America they're spending $700 more a
month to buy the exact same things that
they bought two years ago much at a much
lower price I mean groceries and gas and
clothes for their kids and this is what
bomic is delivering and that's why we're
working so hard in Virginia to try to
keep the cost of living down in fact
this week Sean we're sending out our tax
refund checks $200 for those filing
individually and $400 for those filing
jointly because it's their money not the
governments we're doing everything we
can to keep tax rates tax rates down and
provide Virginia a chance to make ends
meet in this Biden economy so two weeks
from tomorrow it's actually 15 days not
17 days uh you have a really important
election and that right now the state
senate is a a four vote Mar a four vote
lead by democrats over Republicans House
of delegates Republicans have a five
vote majority um you're pushing really
hard for to for Republicans to get
control of both houses before your
election I thought Virginia was gone I
thought Republicans would never be
competitive again okay how realistic is
that the house of delegates and the
Senate goes
Republican Sean our elections are on a
knife's edge uh we can hold our house
and flip our Senate but every single one
of the key races is tight and we are
doing everything down the stretch to get
the vote out you know the the winner of
election is the one who gets the most
votes it's the people that show up and
so we're pushing hard to get Republicans
off the sidelines that's why we pushed
we pushed our early voting program so
hard early on so why we're asking
everybody to go to secureye virginia.com
make a plan to vote early we got two
weeks to get the vote out in fact this
Saturday every one of our precincts will
be open early we've got to get the vote
out and if we do this Sean we can in
fact demonstrate that in 24 short months
a state that was lost can be found and
Common Sense conservative leadership
delivers I mean we just said we just set
a job growth record with
230,000 more Virginia working in just 22
months of work when we came in we were
near the bottom and now we're near the
top and job growth we have the largest
Workforce in the history of Virginia
elections have consequences and that's
why we're pushing so hard to get
everybody out to vote we've got great
answers to the challenges of today job
growth empowering parents back in the
blue making government work for people
as opposed to telling them what to do
all the time and all the other side has
is to self fear we are going to drive
through this to the end we did it in
2021 and here's our chance to show yet
again that Common Sense conservative
leadership not only works but even those
voters who who are in the middle and
many Democrats come along with us in
order to show that Virginia will lead
again and demonstrate to the nation that
we can turn a state completely around
Governor every single Republican every
conservative in every state needs to
adopt your mentality vote early vote by
mail Bank your vote whatever you want to
call it if your state has legal ballot
harvesting get involved in that as well
uh it's going to be very interesting
just well 2 weeks from tomorrow is the
big day Governor great to have you thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else